I want to I've always wanted to ask you
this and I don't know if it's like
folklore but in the 90s when you were on
MTV yes
us Comics open mikers would talk how
much Bill Bellamy is making on MTV yes
and somebody had told me you make ten
thousand dollars a week back then is
that true
uh I I don't know how much I made in a
week I know that I was the highest paid
wow I was
um
like when I came to MTV I think I was
making like 250 a year whoa when I left
I was at 600 000. a year
in the 90s yeah because what happened
was so different I was I shot out of
like a rocket like I got you know they
gave me like a screen test kind of thing
because you got to understand I did it
for like seven years wow and I got
really popular so I leveraged that you
know wow because the other person that
was highly paid was Cindy Crawford
[__] they wasn't paying nobody bro I was
on Mad TV you know how much I made a
dollar right yeah I made my first year
every episode I would make
four thousand dollars
I'm on a network TV show 4 000 right and
they got four grand a week no and I was
like oh [__] but at the time though I'm
like yeah because you just open micros
right right right like but but you got
to understand like you said coming from
an open mic or to making four thousand a
week
that's actually not horrible it's not
really but like it no it really isn't
because you because you know you open
mic you knew you trying to get on I mean
I get it but like once you get on like
for me
I had I had two things in my favor I was
not just a guy off the street I was
already making noise right yeah so I was
on HBO uh Def Comedy Jam then I got HBO
young comedian specialist wow Ray Romano
and Nick to follow and I was just like
rolling uh um and then then I got MTV
and it was like
they were like oh my God you know we
need we need a black guy that's funny
that knows the music and this and the
other and at first I was just doing MTV
Jams you know like all the urban you
know top 40. yeah and then when I was
getting good at it I was like oh well
they were like but let's let them do top
40. yeah you know pop like all the pop
music with rock bands and everything so
now I got this eclectic sort of diverse
palette for music so now I'm bigger than
that I'm not just you know the black guy
over here I'm sitting here with Kurt
Cobain I'm talking to Janet I'm talking
to Madonna you know and so that's how I
blew up so then when it was time to
negotiate get the bag
I know because we were looking at you
going oh my God that's the life right
there it was super fun everybody
everyone
always wanted to to have that job you
know and and it was definitely a lot of
fun because it was like
how hard is it to do comedy we're funny
guys like you know what I mean imagine
just like being on the beach and telling
your own really funny jokes and being in
your personality and getting paid for
that that's all it was yeah but I just
had to know the music though so
basically I could be myself but I did
have to study the music like I need to I
need to listen to your album I need to
know you know producers you get so you
had to get sharp you had to be sharp on
your music so then when you were talking
you could be fluent I didn't want to you
had to learn [__] that you didn't like I
would have never known like I didn't I
didn't learn I didn't grunge was new
[Music]
but these genres you gotta understand
and this is why I think people are going
to really like my book top billing is
because I'm walking you through like it
was as if a uh a window opened up or a
like a
just just a Vortex opened up and MTV
allowed all this new talent to come
through it because they were just doing
rock yeah initially it was just
right yeah and then when I got there
like 92 they were like okay well we're
gonna take a little chance on Michael
Jackson because Michael Jackson wasn't
even on it wow Michael Jackson gets on
then you got Madonna's on there then you
got like you getting these little cool
little bands you know Aerosmith yeah you
know yeah sure but we were on it in 1992
yeah wow what a fun time it was fun
beautiful that's when we was buying
records this one we was going to Tower
Records I used to be a Tower Records for
three hours buying album yeah yeah there
was a Tower Records in Hollywood right
on Sunset yeah oh no there was a virgin
one too remember virgin on Sunset right
and every Monday they would have new
release I would go there every Monday
and then they'd listen to the music bro
yeah you could yeah I talk about that in
my book is like that was the essence of
when if you was a real music lover that
was a moment for you like if you love
music you you knew that uh Fridays was
getting released about six seven albums
the new tribe album was coming out you
actually knew like every genre that was
dropping yeah and so you could go there
and Sample and they had headphones like
all like Frozen for that yeah you
remember that and you'd be like and and
you would come up to me and ask me
something like huh
okay hi hi I'm listening you might want
to check out this new album it's good
yeah it was it was like it was like a
cool
like a community of people that music
lovers yeah yeah I love that yeah now
this might not be appropriate I don't
know if you've already addressed this
but I'm asking because she just played
the Hollywood Bowl over the weekend and
all my friends went to it but like did
you have a thing with Janet Jackson ever
um yes but not like you think our thing
was just we liked each other I think
like we never crossed the line no no no
we hung out all the time whoa and I went
on tour with her and uh it was really
interesting you know what I'm saying
because I felt like Janet
had a crush on me but like would not
cross the line what does that feel like
crazy it's just been like my queen for
so long especially growing up I think it
was my humor like I made her comfortable
or something like she was like Bill
you're so crucial who's Janet Jackson
and so you know I'm not thinking that I
this is how silly I am I she's she's a
superstar I'm a young trying to be a
star right so I don't even realize that
I could even get to that level because
she's selling out Arenas and I'm doing
small theaters in clubs yeah yeah and
she's Superstar and she calls me and
says I want you to go into a room whoa
and I'm like me
oh my God but is there anyone you're
have you because you've been around a
lot of dudes right and famous people is
there anyone that you're intimidated by
or no
like you're hanging out with them you're
like holy [__] I'm hanging out with
so-and-so yeah Michael Jordan was
intimidating a little holy [__] you you
hung out with him yeah because Michael
yes that's me and Janet
life's very nice it was very nice and
she was very kind to me I always love
her for that like she was just like
she'd like it was almost as if
I was a little brother but then it was
always this feeling like you know you
could get it whoa
whoa just a teaspoon yeah yeah she liked
the BD who's giving you that energy oh
[__] oh [__] that's a good question yeah
dude I don't look sexual to these people
that's wrong what do you mean wrong you
think Sarah Jessica Parker was like I
want to [__] no no I think you're
such a sexual being